your credit score is a measure some
would argue an imperfect measure of how
likely you are to pay for things on time
let's say you were to take a loan how
likely are you to
pay make the payments on that loan if
you were to get a lease on an apartment
how likely are you to pay rent on time
now there are three credit bureaus there
are transunion experian and equifax and
what happens is is let's say that you
have a credit card and as you pay that
credit card the pay the balance or pay
the minimum payment on time or you don't
pay on time that gets reported to these
bureaus these bureaus use an algorithm
that comes from a company called fico it
used to stand for fair isaac's
corporation and that gives you a score
and each of the three bureaus will have
a score between 300 and 850. if you have
a score near the high end of that range
if you're in the high 700s or above that
is an excellent credit rating
people will give you loans it will be
easy for you to lease things and not
only when you get that loan it will
actually be at a lower interest rate
if your credit score is in the
600 to low 700 range that's decent
you're probably okay although you might
in certain cases have to pay a higher
interest rate than the people with the
excellent credit and then if your credit
score is in the low range which would be
anywhere from 300 to say the high 500s
you're going to have trouble getting a
loan or in many cases getting a lease or
if you do you're going to have to pay a
higher interest rate now the ways to get
a as high a credit rating as possible is
pay your bills on time pay your rent on
time have a long credit history it's
good to have credit so it's good to have
a credit card that has a high limit but
to use as little of that as possible so
good luck with your credit scores